the pandemic kept us apart physically in
many ways it also brought us together as
a country
so let's take a look now back shall we
at the fun times including
before we needed to socially distance
remember that when was that
time yeah when was that roll the tape ms
shantae
i know but he said what do you got okay
[Laughter]
you cannot plan spontaneity that's the
beauty of what we do
we're coming to you from each of our
homes this morning because we
like you are practicing social
distancing out of an abundance of
caution
do you wear mask elmo yeah wearing a
mask helps anybody stay healthy do all
the vaccines work the same david or is
are some better than others for instance
for a 67 year old woman
who's wearing purple today no no no no
i'm sorry number one you're neither 64
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
security i used to really like you
i never asked you for anything lenny are
you going to wear your sunglasses the
whole time
this is early you can do whatever you
want lenny kravitz
are we catching you two at a bad time is
up the marital bed
this is where the magic does not happen
oh
wow yes did you have a little chicken
for breakfast
[Music]
tony may have been stung by a bee but
vlad
is all the buzz when my day is going
slow i don't get mad
i get flat it may be getting cold
outside but vladius always comes in hot
vlad is better than my morning bacon is
that even possible i don't think so
because we sizzled how was it for you mr
begna very good as we say in louisiana
sauce bone
it was sausage bone good very good
your first job was as a hand model but
it gone differently let me see your
hands
yeah not bad you know what i'm gonna say
all right all right
i'm a hustler baby
i mean you've written so many songs do
you have any favorites i mean it changes
for me all the time what is it now
good i almost answered that question
mr mason is good
why is anthony mason standing there with
a firefighter jacket on
drew barrymore it's good to see you and
i wore yellow in your honor i wore
yellow in your honor you got a yellow
mic
yes is that ours no i brought it down
how did you get that i know what to get
gail as a president
it's almost thanksgiving
you dream big we got a latte going on
around here
we've got a latte going on a big big day
so we're in a big big space we're coming
to you from our cbs news election
headquarters today
with election day am i proud of my tv
gimmick yes i am please i'm begging you
to take it away
are you still wearing the same clothes
you had on yesterday i am
bed and a belly rub sound pretty good
right now
[Music]
break out the blue balloons our favorite
baby panda is
a boy all together now you have a new
name
they call me frampo
[Laughter]
i'm stuck with it spotify's got the big
songs of 2020.
your dad jeans are going lizzo happened
in middle school we would just put
o on the end of our name lizzo and gaylo
anthony yo antonio i like that too
you say you're happier now than you've
ever been you've you gotta work on it
every single day
all the people that didn't participate
i'm gonna remember y'all
how long are we doing this can we call
it do you think we'll be sitting here at
102
i'll go first i don't know i don't think
they'll let us sit here at 100
[Music]
an older american that's right dancing
for some good cause
i can't remember all the details that's
right um that's right i can't
i don't ever want to see that video
again though it's scalding me just my
eyes hurt
dancing that was fun that was fun it's
okay listen i'm doing the same dance as
i was doing in seventh grade
i'm glad we can still get up and move
special shout out to you kate gilhool
kelly yes velez who edited those pieces
those are hard to do
thanks for a great year thank you thank
you